Cette pièce d'acier doit supporter le poids d'une petite maison.
Elle coûte environ 20 000 euros, et là-dessus, Guy Job ne peut rien faire.
- Ce châssis, c'est pas nous qui le fabriquons, c'est les constructeurs automobiles, bien évidemment.
Et c'est 50 % du coût de revient du véhicule.
Et c'est sur ce châssis que tout va se jouer.
C'est là que l'on pose le plancher, autrement dit, la base du futur camping-car.
- La grande difficulté, c'est de loger dans un espace aussi réduit...
Si vous prenez 10 à 12 m2, c'est la dimension d'une chambre d'hôtel.
Et vous allez devoir loger dans cette dimension, dans cet espace-là,
la totalité des fonctionnalités du véhicule,
qui sont des fonctionnalités identiques à ce que vous avez à la maison,
voire au-delà, parce que vous devez pouvoir fonctionner en totale autonomie, etc.
C'est donc là, sur ce petit socle de 10 à 12 m2,
qu'il va falloir faire tenir une salle de bain, une cuisine, une chambre,
un salon, des rangements et des toilettes.
Il faut être un peu magicien,
surtout quand on sait que cette future maison miniature ne doit pas peser trop lourd.
Car Guy Job doit tout faire pour que son camping-car ne dépasse jamais les 3,5 tonnes.
Car dans ce cas, il entrerait dans la catégorie poids lourds.
Là, il ne serait plus accessible au permis voiture.
Alors Guy doit l'alléger en permanence.
Et voici comment il réduit par exemple le poids des parois internes.
- Ca va ? Tu m'as préparé 2 panneaux ?
- Voilà.
En apparence, ces 2 panneaux de contreplaqué sont identiques.
Et pourtant, une fois posés sur la balance,
le 1er pèse un peu plus de 10 kg et l'autre un peu moins de 8 kg.
Mais où sont passés les 2 kg ?
Regardez bien ces 2 panneaux. Ils sont de même épaisseur.
Mais le plus lourd est un panneau plein,
alors que le plus léger comporte des portions creuses.
Un allègement inspiré d'un tout autre secteur d'activité.
- Nous n'avons pas inventé cette technique,
elle est issue, historiquement, de l'aviation et autres,
qui ont a l'habitude d'alléger systématiquement leurs panneaux.
Des panneaux allégés qui donnent l'illusion d'avoir du bois massif.
Mais pour Guy, le plus difficile réside dans l'assemblage de toutes ces pièces.
A priori, l'opération s'annonce très coûteuse
car il faut mobiliser des électriciens, des plombiers, des menuisiers,
une dizaine de corps de métiers différents.
60 salariés, 2 jours de travail quasi impossibles à robotiser.
Alors pour éviter que les prix ne dérapent, un maximum de pièces est standardisé,
comme cet évier conçu à 5 000 exemplaires.
Rien à voir avec les modèles des années 60.
A l'époque, les camping-cars, c'était ça, des maisons de luxe sur roues,
des modèles uniques bricolés par des artisans qui ne lésinaient pas sur les matériaux.
Bois massif, nappes brodées, du velours sur les banquettes,
de la moquette au sol, des frigos et des cuisinières spécialement conçus
et même du carrelage dans la salle de bain.
Une échelle à l'intérieur et une autre à l'extérieur
permettaient d'accéder à une galerie sur le toit.
Mais cette époque est bel et bien révolue.
Aujourd'hui, les camping-cars sont produits à la chaîne.
Par exemple, l'assemblage des parois extérieures se répète 23 fois par jour.
Une opération délicate effectuée avec des vis et de la colle.
Tout s'emboîte comme dans un Lego géant.
- Voilà, eh bien, c'est la mise en place des parois.
A l'inverse de la maison, où on construit d'abord la maison,
et ensuite, on l'équipe avec du mobilier, chez nous, vous vous êtes aperçus,
d'abord, on met le mobilier en position, en situation,
et ensuite, on va venir mettre les murs au toit.
Et pour baisser les prix, Guy et son équipe ont une idée :
simplifier leur engin au maximum.
Il ne garde que les fonctions essentielles,
à savoir le salon, la cuisine, la chambre et la salle de bain.
Tout le reste passe en option.
Par exemple, regardez bien l'arrière de ce Challenger, celui de l'année 1985.
Il possède une échelle extérieure. Eh bien, cet accessoire a disparu du modèle 2015.
Certes, l'échelle existe toujours, mais cette fois-ci sur catalogue.
Si vous la voulez, il faudra la commander, 615 euros en plus.
En simplifiant ainsi le camping-car, en standardisant sa production,
Trigano a réussi il y a 20 ans à le vendre 15 % moins cher que ses concurrents.
Une révolution à l'époque.
Depuis, l'entreprise qui fabriquait de simples tentes
est devenue le leader incontesté des camping-cars en France.
Sauf qu'aujourd'hui, Trigano n'est plus le seul sur ce créneau.
La concurrence est rude.
Elle s'appelle Rapido, Pilote, Burstner ou encore Adria,
et elle n'a qu'une envie : détrôner le roi Trigano avec une promesse encore plus forte :
proposer des équipements qui épatent les consommateurs au prix le moins cher possible.